we've been talking about echo chambers
that are created online based on these
recommendation algorithms that exist
so this happens on facebook this happens
on youtube
this is happening on uh instagram
twitter i'm not sure if they have this
type of of algorithm
in place but many places online you were
shown
videos or articles or posts
that are based on an algorithm that
determines what you are most likely
to engage with based on how you've
reacted to other content what have you
shared what have you spent time
looking at what have you clicked on or
liked or whatever the case may be
this can be problematic because
algorithms can be gamed and algorithms
can also recommend
content that for a variety of different
reasons we might not want to see
recommended youtube is one big place
where this has been really really
controversial and youtube made an
announcement over the weekend in a blog
post
that they're going to stop or at least
reduce recommendations of what they call
quote borderline content and content
that could
misinform users in harmful ways such as
videos promoting a phony miracle cure
for a serious illness claiming the earth
is flat
or making blatantly false claims about
historic events like 911
so the idea here is um if we look at
alex jones as an example before he was
he was kicked off of youtube
the idea is there are some very widely
viewed videos for example about
sandy hook shooting conspiracy theories
and when it becomes a problem is if
people go on youtube
and they just want information about the
event and they search for
i don't know what happened at sandy hook
or something like that
they could get a conspiracy video of
alex jones claiming
it was a false flag with paid crisis
actors it didn't happen in the way that
supposedly the news tells us that it
happened
that's an example what youtube is saying
is not that they're going to ban the
content itself unless it violates terms
and conditions which is sort of a
different story
but what they're saying is they'll tweak
the algorithm so that if you're just
searching around for information on some
of these topics
you're not going to get conspiracy
videos placed
in front of you how much content will
this impact youtube says that this will
impact less than one percent of all
content on youtube and again this is not
about whether the content is or isn't
allowed that's not changing
um the reactions have been pretty
predictable some so-called free speech
absolutists are saying
it's censorship this is an attack on
constitutionally protected free speech
and they're saying all of the things
you would anticipate they would say
other people are saying well hold on a
second
youtube can decide what content it wants
to promote
and what content it doesn't want to
promote the recommendation algorithm
is merely how youtube expresses what it
wants to put a spotlight on
and what it doesn't nothing illegal is
happening here
is uh uh is this something that could
inadvertently hurt people who aren't
doing anything wrong
sure yeah i mean people spreading
misinformation
are going to be hurt by this and they're
going to be at a disadvantage
but people who are also doing great
stuff are going to probably end up
inadvertently caught up in this as well
here's the reality the recommendation
algorithm on youtube
has always favored some content over
others
it's changing all the time it's never
worked perfectly the david pakman show
youtube channel
has been hurt by algorithm changes
at different points in time we've had
content that didn't do as well
because of how the algorithm is
configured we've had content that was
pushed viral
on a whim that we didn't even understand
because of the algorithm
i think that if we are given the choice
between knowing more about how the
algorithm works
and knowing less i prefer to know more
at least they're being upfront about
this tweak what people need to
understand
is that either way youtube is doing this
stuff
i'd rather know about it people can
choose not to use youtube if they so
choose uh
and i am at risk for sure and people
could say but david aren't you going to
change your mind about this if it ends
up hurting you
you're not going to be so lazy fair
about it it has hurt me
at times what can i do youtube can have
an algorithm
it's ultimately up to me to decide uh is
being on youtube at all
a net positive or a net negative and i
can decide whether to keep putting my
content there
i'm going to focus my time on making
good content and promoting good ideas
if youtube becomes too oppressive if my
traffic goes down because of the
algorithm
then i'll start looking for other
platforms but the people who are wanting
to have it both ways here saying
that companies should be allowed to do
what they want as long as they're not
breaking the law
but at the same time youtube's algorithm
can't
de-prioritize conspiratorial content
and sham medical treatments and all of
this other stuff how can you possibly
take both of those positions it doesn't
make any sense